and joining us in the Direct TV 4k
college football report as a man who's
calling a huge game in the Big Ten
perhaps the biggest game in the Big Ten
this year with all due respect to
Wisconsin fans Penn State at Ohio State
3:30 p.m. Eastern on Fox
welcome to Rich Eisen show Gus Johnson
how you doing Gus Richie Rich what's up
big fella it has been - it's been too
long since we've chatted you don't love
me anymore of it I'm not big enough for
your show that is that is fake news Gus
Johnson knows tag hey hey fake news is
part of our world today but so we're
allowed to use it so what do you have
for me and Columbus did you just chat
with the coaches of you where are you in
your preparation so far reasonable we
just left the coaches at Ohio State and
we talked to Erin and Greg Schiano you
know all the coaches there Larry Johnson
and you know their disability you know
they're well one thing and as you
remember as you know rich there when a
big game is getting ready to take place
there is a beautiful paranoia that teams
have and they were fully engaged in the
paranoia in terms of everything was on
lockdown at Ohio State I mean is on
lockdown at Ohio State we normally get a
chance to talk to the coach you know 45
30 to 45 minutes he was like listen you
got five minutes and you're out of my
office
so we had a good five minutes why don't
you Meyer
he chucked us and we talked to both the
offensive defensive coordinators and
coach Johnson the assistant head coach
and they pretty much wanted us they
pretty much kicked us out pretty fast so
I mean this is it I mean right I mean
certainly after what Penn State did to
Michigan last week just torn limb from
limb in the same way that Michigan did
to Penn State last year they are
absolutely settling old scores and Ohio
State has won against Penn State last
year for sure so what do you think Penn
State's mindset is coming into this game
because well you know we're getting
ready to go talk to coach Franklin and
his staff as soon as I get off the phone
with you we're gonna go drive over to
their hotel it's about 20 25 minute
drive so we don't know as of yet but
I know you're a your Wolverine so you
saw that game last week and Penn State
came out and played you know one of
their best games of the season and I
think that being the number two team in
the nation and looking what they had
looking at what they have on tape I
think they're fully ready prepared and
confident about this game against Ohio
State even though it's on the road and I
feel that they they think they can come
out of this thing victorious and get
back to Happy Valley in even better
shape Gus Johnson was calling Ohio State
Penn State joining me here from Columbus
Ohio on the Rich Eisen show that number
26 jumps off a film doesn't he Gus ooh
he's awesome rich this kid this kid is
say quantum Berkeley is who he's talking
about folks number 26 for Penn State
their star running back and he is just
phenomenal
and Ohio State's are really worried
about him I mean really really really
worried about him he's a Heisman Trophy
candidate and if he has a big game
tomorrow he could seal the deal for
himself who knows but just a spectacular
Talent spectacular kid and and and you
know this is why we watch because we
want to see the best players play
against each other the best teams play
against each other and we're gonna get
an opportunity to see that tomorrow Penn
State against Ohio State again 3:30 p.m.
Eastern Time on Fox at the Horseshoe
where again uuuuhhhh you've already
called a game this year who's the best
team you've seen personally I bawled so
far this year Gus no hi O state state's
the best team I've seen I mean I had USC
early and I thought that they were they
had a chance to be really good but
injuries I think hurt him so much and
they're not the same team as I saw
earlier in the season because Ohio State
team in all phases of the game
especially on offense and defense they
got some shaky special teams this year
but we'll see it looks like that's
something they can correct but you know
offensively and defensively I think JT
Barrett
is starting to really play some
incredible football and I think a big
game by JT tomorrow and he'll get it
it'll really start to turn a lot of
heads for the Heisman Trophy but they
they have this new passing attack this
new offensive scheme and you know
they're doing a lot of underneath routes
mesh routes they call it and stuff like
that and I think they've tailored it to
JT strengths and I think it's gonna
allow him to hit the deep ball later on
during the season maybe even tomorrow so
and offensively I mean they're they're
d-line is just awesome with Hubbard guys
like Nick Bosa young chase young I mean
I think they have maybe the best
offensive line in the nation and it
could cause some problems for Penn State
so well you know a place is gonna be
rockin we're gonna see Gus Johnson
joining me here on the Rich Eisen show
in the DirecTV 4k college football
report all right Gus I want to get into
some of the stuff up and Dinah asked you
for a long time did you make a deal with
somebody years ago that every single
game you call either comes down to the
last second or has some what do you got
for me Gus what happened yours well you
know I try to stay prayed up rich so I
think me and the big man upstairs you
know he understands my heart he
understands that I want to be the
conduit between him and the message he
wants to get out to the people and I've
been very blessed and very fortunate
that's the prayer I always say before
every game I said Lord I'll say lord
please allow me to be a conduit between
which you're between you and the message
you want to get out to the masses so I I
can't explain it man I just can't and
I'm not gonna try to explain it I'm
happy about it I don't want to jinx it
but I have been a great I have been
apart you know when you you know
sometimes I look back and I just think
wow you know this is this is amazing I
don't even know if I have any more gas
for it I just turned 50 ritm Gus it's
just a number come on now that's a
number
know what they ate rich are you 58 I'm
48 okay you know what they say about a
black man that makes 50 right what does
that know they say he doing good
Gus I gotta tell you you know who's you
you know who would say who who would say
something like that to me if he was
around still you know I'm talking about
rights to who yes
dude that was love it that's all I know
boy he's our boy [ __ ]
I know I know and even you know I talked
to him at the Super Bowl when the Super
Bowl was in in New York one of the and
if I ever do write a book you know
there'll be a part of the book that I'll
dedicate to him and that conversation
that I had and I was sitting there talk
to him he was late at night you know he
had his lady with him and I said man I
don't know why I asked this question is
probably inappropriate I said man when
you go to sleep at night do you worry
that you might not wake up and he says
yeah I do every night and the reason
that I worry that I might not wake up is
because I worried that I won't be able
to see my daughters get married you know
I might not be able to see the little
things in life that we all know is so
important when it comes to the people
that we love and I'll never forgot that
man you know he was strong into the end
he was positive he was hopeful man what
a great person crazy mid being right
back at you Gus I mean he'd loved you he
really enjoyed watching you and you know
the the lines that would just come out
of your your mouth and your skull for
big moments like that you know he did
love you and I got I speak for a lot of
sports fans we missed you doing college
hoops Gus do you miss it
oh man I miss it
like I would miss not breathing you know
it was that big a part of my life and
obviously I meant March Madness is what
I meant I know your home college exactly
like I said I've miss it like you would
miss not breathing but you know we grow
we change we we have to do things
sometimes to make sure that we
secure the future for our families so we
have to sometimes make tough decisions
maybe not the decision that we want to
make at that time but the decision that
is the right decision for you as you try
to that Hank Stram would say matriculate
down the field of life so yeah man I
miss it a lot I wish I could still be a
part of it but you know right now that's
not the deal and I root and watch the
tournament like a fan and and and I'm
satisfied with that for right now so
again you're just 50 though lots of time
lots of time less Gus you never know
crazier things have happened in this
world hey hey UCLA was down by 40 came
back and won and who called that game
Gus Gus Johnson games that's why we call
him Gus Johnson games that's why it's
called that man that's so cool man that
is so cool right back at you cuz let's
make this a regular one so once every
once in a while you call it a show you
know I mean you know I mean I know I got
a call the biggest game in the college
football season is for you to call me
you know I'm being very
passive-aggressive now well so I mean
you know if I I mean if you feel like if
you don't have anybody else
you know let's put on you can always
call me rich and you know I'll do
whatever you need man we go back a long
way yes we do Gus have a great broadcast
tomorrow I will be watching and we will
be chatting again very soon okay okay
baby
mommy you got it that's Gus Johnson man
he is just awesome that guy knows only
one speed Gus Johnson for more Rich
Eisen show tuned to audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the
doesn't show up